welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on why you should
never ever come between a mother bearer
and her cubs especially if that mother
bear has ripped a hole between universes
to get to those cubs my name is mt and
i'm here today with off-screen producer
brandon what's going on brandon hello mt
you should also never come between a
bear and his pot of honey yes uh you'll
be oh bothered into the afterlife oh
father where's my honey i need my honey
is literally my favorite disney
character of all time so i feel like my
impression should be better he's a man
on a mission he wants that honey
seriously like winnie the pooh is the
most unproblematic disney character i
feel the rest of them garbage we need
the poop you know what would be
problematic if they gave them fingers
imagine a witty the poo with like five
fingers on each hand that would be
creepy i don't like it uh that's
nightmare fuel brandon uh
very upset that you put that into my
imagination that's now in the multiverse
that's now that now exists it exists
there's a wedding in the pool with
fingers but what's our big question for
today brandon well mt dr strange and the
multiverse of madness has been out in
theaters for over a week now and we
still have so much to talk about we've
been covering it on this channel like
crazy you know spoiler alert we're all
gonna we're gonna talk about this movie
yes huge spoiler alert huge mt gave you
a big spoiler right off the top uh but
if you don't know by now that we're the
spoiler gates are open on this movie
it's too late
it's too late to even turn back but now
that that multiverse has been fully
cracked open we can really start
thinking about all the different
versions of our favorite characters that
exist in other universes but what about
our very own red queen is she the most
dangerous version in the universe it all
leads us to this week's big question
does the 616 mcu universe contain the
most evil version of wanda maximoff
that's a great question because the
mcu's wanda max buff has fully embraced
her title as the scarlet witch as we've
seen
by the disappearance of one black bolt's
mouth fulfilling a prophecy of an ultra
powerful being originally laid out in
the darkhold and it's very clear that
the darkhold had corrupted wanda because
in the final episode of wandavision we
saw her free the citizens of west view
and come to terms with the loss of
vision and on top of that she had to let
go of her very own children which she
assumed had been merely created as part
of her grief for losing vision but as
the post-credit scene of wild division
showed us she kept examining the
contents of the darkhold to learn more
about her own chaos magic powers but the
darkhold took this opportunity to show
her that her children were real they
exist in countless other universes as
opposed to this one and it's on this
very subject that the darkhold
corruption was able to take hold by the
time we meet up with wanda again in
multiverse of madness she has fully
embraced the power of the darkhold in
order to be reunited with her children
that everyone keeps telling her are just
made up but she can very clearly see
that they are real and do exist in some
reality so yeah what do you think here i
think you're right empty it's like and
we're not saying wanda is a bad person
or is like crazy or is is like an evil
deep down because i think in the in the
movie you really saw that moment uh when
uh 838 wanda's kind of talking to her
and she sees like the kids crying and
she kind of breaks out of it and she's
like i would never hurt you i would
never hurt anybody she says spoiler
alert you just heard a ton of people you
know it's like
i i do believe that like
you know i've seen people kind of
complain they're like oh it kind of
changed the end of one division but not
really right yeah at the end of one
division she had kind of put away
she'd put away that grief and she'd come
to terms with it but then she has the
dark cold she's hanging out at a cabin
she's trying to be chill she's trying to
learn more about herself because no
one's telling her anything and she gets
you know she hears her kids cry out for
her and that's where the dark hole
starts like taking hold of her because
this movie showed us that like whoever
uses the uses the darkhold gets
corrupted right yeah and like what i
really do love about this movie is like
you're exactly right because like it's
it's sort of a movie about addiction in
a sort of a weird cosmic way because
like you know we see that agatha
harkness she had this dark hole and her
her mom act like her mom was like hey
you have this knowledge and you are a
threat like much like we see a
multiverse of madness so her mom tried
to kill her because of that um she could
potentially destroy the whole universe
like doc this other illuminati strange
does so um yeah i definitely feel like
this dark hold is just like this
cosmically addicting thing like it was
in the comics and has corrupted so many
people i was like anybody who touches
the darkhold you're screwed i
need it
like you just don't do it um so like i
definitely don't think that wanda is a
villain or is evil and she's just like
this this darkhold is just really
right really messing with her um
because she's getting which it's just it
hits harder as you pointed out empty you
know people tell her all the time like
her kids don't exist she just made them
up because they can't see what she sees
they don't know what she knows and like
even doctor strange in this movie says
to wanda like you made those kids up and
she's like no she didn't they exist and
she's now she's found out that like
every other universe she's got kids and
in this one they're not giving her kids
and this one everyone gets to come back
except for the love of her life right he
doesn't get to come back and when he
does come back he gets taken away again
like
these these are the things she's dealing
with and it's pushed her to this point
of of i'm gonna do what i want to get my
kids who i see is mine and like again
it's not just her it's the dark hold
corrupting her and like putting her in
this mind state this is the most evil
force in the the multiverse and she has
it like attached to her and she's like
the most powerful version of herself
right so of course the dark hold is
going to draw her further and further in
and make her reach out and and get what
she wants to make her powerful
destroying other universes while she
does it which is exactly just crazy
super powerful i honestly feel like this
dark hold is a sentient being and like
it has its own goal much like the mind
stone in a way that in in the previous
movies but in this case it's probably
just filling the entire universe with
darkness which is what happens with um
illuminati strange and so like i think
that it just tries to get it tries to
play on you what you want and your
desires and then it's like all right i
can work with this let's just use that
to accidentally fill the world with
darkness why not um so it's just a very
tricky tone don't mess with it we need
that blade to tell these people to stop
touching things
we do we do he's got to be out there
warning people i mean agatha tried to
warn her she was like you're not ready
for this don't take that straight out
and like agatha was even like i'll help
you and she's like no i'm gonna leave
you here in westview with your brain
locked in which was like a big mistake
and like hubris is what gets people in
trouble it's what got the illuminati in
trouble was hubris like thinking you can
control these things and there's tons of
examples of people who have interacted
with the darkhold warning other people
like don't mess with this but that
that's a story across time right
it's what the jedi deal with they tell
anakin like don't don't look into this
stuff and he's like i want to look into
this stuff like i need to know dr
strange he wanted to look into dark
magic uh adam and eve you know they they
wanted to eat the apple like they want
to know what's going on this is like the
story of humanity like we try and keep
our children from getting hurt but they
need to learn lessons on their own and
sometimes they went on the hard way
and that's what happened here i love
what you're saying about like the
darkness taking over the universe
because that's another big theme in
marvel right we saw it with malekith and
the dark elves right they wanted to
they wanted the universe started as
darkness they wanted to go back to that
we see it with dora mamu who's coming
back my boy he's coming back baby boy
dormammu wanted to consume ever all the
life and like just bring dark uh magic
and dark energy to the whole cosmos so
yeah that is like a good
goal for the dark cold is just like
spread its darkness across the
multiverse and consume everything it can
darkness absorbs light and it just
doesn't like all this light like you
said because the universe the mcu
originally was dark and like all these
light colonizers like the as guardians
of the celestials came in and just
started making all these stars so yeah
the dark hole probably wants to do what
malikith wanted to do and flooded back
all with darkness
but yeah but there's another version of
wanda that we saw a little bit of in the
film and that was the wanda from the
universe of a38 which is this new huge
illuminati universe that we have in the
mcu and this one that has her kids billy
and tommy and maybe even a vision that's
still alive possibly who knows and this
a38 wanda also has powers which we saw
her display when she flew out of that
gap junction after 616 left her body but
this wanda also never realized the full
extent of her abilities as she never
went through the events of the westview
hex or came in contact with the darkhold
and it makes sense why the 838
illuminati would be so dismissive of
616's strange when he warned them about
616 wanda to them wanda is not really
much of a threat because in their
reality she's just chilling a3 and 838
christine palmer is a senior fellow at
the baxter institute studying the
multiverse and knowing what the 838
illuminati went through with their
doctor strange it would make sense that
they would look at all the different
versions of powered individuals across
the multiverse to see who could be a
potential threat and that's why they
tell 616 strange that the doctor
strangers across the multiverses are
usually a threat because they haven't
been able to see the potential threat
that our 616 wanda poses so why were
they so blind and so freaking arrogant
like jesus christ these guys are the i'd
be like i love the illuminati they're
very smart people i'm sure that they've
done a lot of like help for the
multiverse before they all got uh
eliminated but these guys are just like
why we can handle your little witch are
you sure are you really sure are you
sure about that i think even like the
illuminati in marvel comics right is
problematic in that much like this
illuminati we saw on the film they're
there to protect their universe at the
cost of any other universe right so if
they see an incursion coming
they're gonna try and stop it but at the
end of the day they're gonna be like we
gotta wipe out that universe before it
wipes out our universe right so there's
always gonna be that going and like this
illuminati as we saw they killed thanos
right before he got all powered up they
didn't live through the sacrifice of
like having half the life in their
universe snapped away you know they kind
of got a little cheat code with the book
of ashanti before he even got all of it
he didn't have all the stones yet so
they're able to just hop in there kill
him and they're like oh we're smart we
know how to do everything right because
we're smart
and yeah i love this idea that uh kind
of like batman right makes a whole list
of how to kill all the justice league
right because he doesn't always trust
them all like you got to imagine that
this 838 illuminati they got access to
the multiverse they know it's out there
they're they're checking them out
they're going to check every powered
individual in their universe right
compare them to all the other ones to
make sure one day all of a sudden uh uh
hawkeye's not gonna go crazy get super
powered up and kill everything right
they check all the other hawkeyes across
the universe which is what they probably
did with strange right they're checking
all these stranges that's why they say
to him like we find that the problem
across the multiverse is usually doctor
strange which i gotta i gotta say sorry
to my boy 616 strange i kept saying he
was the bad one it turns out they're all
the bad ones uh and we got the one good
one my apologies dr stephen strange uh
but yeah they probably i'm sure they
checked in on wanda too because they're
like okay here's a woman who's pretty
powerful let's make sure she's cool
across all the multiverses and i think
they couldn't see 616 at all because of
he who remains right
if you think about like he who remains
was pruning timelines doing all these
things to keep all the other kangs out
right i bet that also prevented them
like 838 from even seeing our multiverse
because kevin feige said he who remains
is gone and that allowed a spell to go
wrong in spider-man no way home which
leads to the entire multiverse going
quite mad i bet like the 616 was like a
blind spot in the multiverse right like
they were probably checking all of them
uh and they just never saw ours like
they have no idea and then all of a
sudden you know he who remains dies i
bet it popped up on the radar i bet
christine palmer was like hey we got
some activity going on out here but they
didn't have time to check in on it when
our doctor strange shows up and he's
like you guys got to be careful about
wanda they're like
wanda we can handle your little weight
right we checked all these witches
across the multiverse they're going to
be fine
and that's why like she totally
surprised them right i think the death
if he who remains is going to have a lot
of ramifications for years to come
across the mcu before he who remains
died he had a lot of plans in motion i
mean we see with a rentslayer we don't
know what he had planned with her if
she's off doing her own thing like this
dude his main goal it seems is to create
the most chaos um and to just like
destroy the timeline because frankly he
just got bored he's like i won and i've
been ruling everything and like i just
i'm tired of winning and i just want to
play as a conqueror again this is boring
doubly eat so like in order to do that i
think that you're totally right like he
i think he's manufactured this whole
wanda situation so that she can go crazy
and destroy the illuminati who manages
um the the multiverse on its in its own
way much like he was doing because he's
probably well aware of these guys exist
he needs to take out this particular
illuminati so that you know more chaos
can reign in the multiverse i bet he
missed the fight right our like he who
remains he he kind of like won right he
had his little his own timeline to live
in he didn't have other kang's coming
trying to kill him because he was
keeping him out but he was probably
bored right he's probably to this is
like fine the one thing he couldn't
control right was the choice that loki
and sylvia had to make he he laid out
the two options and he's like this is
the one thing i'm not going to control
i'm going to leave this up to total
randomness 50 50 chance uh and he winds
up getting killed which was probably a
bummer he was probably sad about that
but he's like this is good uh you know i
get to have the chaos and the multiverse
but now i'm not here to deal with it
like i don't have to fight other kangs
i'm out uh this is everyone else's
problem now
you're right i mean it was his plan to
have wanda at least get to
the point of west view at least get to
that point we don't know
we don't know how it all lines up right
i mean we did that video where like when
he dropped
he drops like that uh that thing on his
desk it kind of syncs up with uh agatha
dropping from the sky or whatever like
yeah maybe i don't know i don't know how
much he planned but he at least planned
for wanda to get to the hex right i
think that yeah we can at least say he
planned that much out and like we know
we do know from uh avengers age of
ultron that you know when thor says
there's there's someone's playing a game
with us with all these infinity stones i
think that this is 100 he who remains
and he was probably working through the
mind stone and um he was just like all
right i'm just making all these events
happen so like we need like all this
scarlet witch massacre and like all this
everything that's happened in the mcu is
specifically for the timeline to go
crazy because he who remains got bored
he's a conqueror at the end of the day
and like he conquered but like it's not
conquering that's the past like you're
now a conqueror you want to be conquer
ring
because that you like the act of doing
it you don't like being a conqueror um
which is very interesting for the
character choice but yeah the other
version of wanda that we know a fair
amount about is the wanda maximal from
the comic books of course and she's a
character who has spent time on both the
side of good and the side of evil
fighting with the mighty avengers to do
good but also spent time teaming up with
the evil brotherhood of mutants and her
most notable event is arguably what
happened during the house of m storyline
where she reshaped all of reality so
that mutants were the dominant race but
then rewrote reality again when she
uttered the phrase no more mutants but
was this a display of wanda being evil
or more likely uh wanda being tired and
of being manipulated the comic books
wanda has we have a ton of reference for
her and she's done like a ton there and
she's been very powerful a lot of times
she's not in control of her powers as
much which is kind of how house of m
happened right but she is a nexus being
in the comic book she's like very
important uh even like they've shown
like the phoenix force was like afraid
of wanda right it knew how powerful
wanda was i don't see the actions of the
house of m as like her being evil
like i don't think she cause she didn't
really intend to do what she did right
yeah like her dad like magneto's the one
yeah yeah like magneto's kind of the one
who tricks her into
like making mutants dominant right like
he's the one that kind of puts her in
that position and it's like wolverine
and some of the gang they start figuring
it out like this isn't real something's
wrong here
uh and then when they kind of kind of
confront her like uh pietro also had a
lot to do with it right he was kind of
like whispering in her ear a lot
uh during the house of m and so she's
just pissed and she's like no more
mutants that's it i'm i'm done i'm i'm
tired right and that kind of
wipes out 90 of the mutants mostly deep
powers them but it does kill some of
them right so that's an evil thing to do
not a nice thing to do but she didn't
intend to do that it's not like she sat
down and she was like i want all these
moons to lose their powers and some of
them to die uh that's the spell i don't
know it's your agenda she just saw her
agenda she wrote that
that was pre-meditated i saw her tumblr
page she she was planning to do this all
the way she pushed a lot of questionable
gifts she had so much power and like she
was in a bad headspace a lot of trauma
in her life in the comics uh so i i
don't put that all on her much like our
wanda in the 616 is being manipulated by
the dark cold mostly uh that wanda in
the comic books like she's being
manipulated by her brother her dad
everything's going crazy there
yeah i don't really blame it on her what
i really love about the marvel universe
in general from the comic books to the
mcu it's like we're seeing how the
effect of like being human but also
having god-like power and like a lot of
these people didn't ask for this
god-like power but they're also dealing
with like stuff like depression which is
what you know wanda deals with in like
in a lot of her
iterations so like you know it's not
wanda's fault that she's sad and like
but she's also a god because then her
god-black powers are reacting to her
emotions i think a lot of the time with
wanda it's just like an accident and
it's just like all right i'm just
working through some [ __ ] and like
whoops i i destroyed reality it's not my
fault it's just an accident
which is kind of
nice and the wanda in the comics like
you know she's trained by agatha
darkness or sorry the one in the
comments
yeah she's trained by agatha harkness uh
for a while so she's she's very aware of
her abilities but it's also not as clear
in the con like she doesn't they don't
know like chaos magic is very
unknown in the comics uh and she's also
you know catholic has like manipulated
her from the very beginning like there's
so much going on in the comics with that
one like she's she's so much a tool of
like dark magic that's being like
manifested through her uh so it's
certainly not like all up to her it's
not like she planned out a lot of this
like it's just like she's so powerful
it's kind of hard to control it's much
like jean grey with the phoenix force i
mean i mentioned it earlier it's like
she's totally different when the phoenix
force has like taken control of her
powers right it's not like it's gene
gray in there it's like the phoenix
making these decisions the wanda in the
616 mcu you know she has no one to teach
her like no one knows how to deal with
this and so she has to rely on this
uh darkhold that to her seems like it
was written just for her like this is
all about me this is what i'm supposed
to do
seriously like i love i love that point
just then because like like in one
division agatha says like your biggest
problem is you're a lack of knowledge
and so like here's this book that's
literally specifically made for you
um by like the cathode who was like
probably your grandpa or some [ __ ] i
don't know um like it was just like kind
of nuts to like you know i if i if i was
in in juan's position i would do the
same exact thing i'd be like oh cool
someone's like someone left a manual
here to teach me oh wait it's an evil
manual whoops um so um yeah in like in
the like you said in the comics agatha
harkness is the sort of mentor for wanda
maximoff so i wonder by the end of house
of harkness if we're going to see like
you know maybe i mean even though wanda
did say like i don't have a cameo in
house of harkness yet but who really
knows i think that at the end of house
of darkness we might see uh wanda maybe
even potentially saving agatha so that
she can agatha could help wanda with her
new corruption because they're both sort
of corrupted it's like hey i don't you
you said that i would need you guess
what i need you now agatha yeah we gotta
fix ourselves here because we really
[ __ ] up um wow
i hope it's agatha that kind of brings
back our wanda you know yes like agatha
is able to break free of her her mind
prison in west view
uh and finds out what happens to wanda
and feels bad because she's like this is
kind of my fault like yeah i was just
trying to take her power
to get it out of someone's hands who
didn't know how to control it a lot of
you know a lot of mirroring with what we
saw with america chavez right it's like
we're just trying to take this power
away from you because you can't handle
it not that we don't like you but we
just want to take your powers away
because it's too dangerous for everyone
else agatha was kind of doing the same
thing and i wonder if she'll feel guilty
being like oh this is all kind of my
fault like i should have been there for
her
i put her in this position so maybe
she'll do something to bring
wanda back i don't know i also think
our boy white vision's gonna bring back
wanda he's gonna be like
you know she brought me back now i'm
gonna bring her back that's that's
that's i hope that's the way i'm gonna
do it i hope that's where he went i hope
that he sort of just knew how this was
going to happen he's like i've got to go
to the
cathode mountain to wait for my wife to
just go crazy and i can help her i'm
honestly surprised white vision didn't
show up at all uh it's kind of weird
that he didn't show up i thought he
might be daddy
which like the 838 vision or like oh
white vision just like in general at any
point like during like he's just like oh
my wife is just just being my wife so
well he doesn't have emotional he
doesn't have emotional attachment to her
yet so he'll get there he's got to
download those memories but not the
emotions
also he's probably like i have to be
married to her no thank you no thank you
she just almost kicked my ass
i'm gonna pass on this yeah i don't i
don't think we should i'm gonna give her
some time to cool off what if what if
white vision just feels awkward because
like he the first thing he did was pick
her up by the throat he's like listen i
can't go back there like she's
he's trying to pilot he's trying to buy
the perfect gift to win her over again
seriously he's like like a cbs looking
at the cards like their apology cards
like i'm sorry for grabbing you by the
throat i don't see it i don't see i'm
sorry for grabbing you by the throat
[Laughter]
uh but i didn't say one other thing um i
think a lot of blame here should go to
the
masters of the mystic arts as well okay
they kind of this is the same problem
right they know the darkhold is evil
they know it's dangerous and instead of
making copies like they should have done
she has a point they just like ban it
outright and they say like no sorcerer
can even go near wonder gore mountain
like we can't learn about it they should
have learned about the dark hold so that
they know how to stop these things and
they know when things are going wrong
don't be worried if your kids are
listening to rock and roll it's gonna
influence in a bad way because you
telling them they can't listen to rock
and roll makes them want to listen to
rock and roll so let these boys read
about dark magic if they start
practicing it that's when we start
cutting off hands cutting off heads
that's fine but let him at least read it
just be like you can read these things
but don't do it don't do it seriously
like it's so weird for the wizards of
commer taj because like their whole
thing is like no knowledge is forbidden
in karma taj like the whole library of
christmas even the high level books were
like hey you could read them but like
you know with the dark hole it's like no
no no you can't really swim no no i'm
sorry it's just like you know obviously
like the dark hole is super corrupted
but it's just like it's kind of almost
hypocritical in a way it's like where
are you guys really i don't know right
um just take out just censor a few words
where you need to to make sure they
can't reach the spell that's all you got
to do and like make sure you put the uh
the consequences uh at the beginning and
rather than the end of the spell like at
the beginning
but there's also another variant of
wanda that should probably talk about
the zombie variant from what if because
she was pretty damn powerful and very
scary yes um and she was quite
i mean i would say evil i mean like i
wouldn't say i mean she was a zombie so
like you you could obviously argue that
zombies are just like animals that have
a certain diet and they have to eat and
like you replicate it's just a different
form of life however this is the darkest
and more more savage wanda that we've
ever seen so what would you think here
well how would you rank yes in terms of
it's tough because you could say like
zombie wanda is the most evil
right and that she's very driven with
one purpose uh and that's like consuming
right taking right she wants to be
reunited with vision as is her way but
she also like wants to consume wants to
take over wants to eat that's like if
you were gonna say like every lion is
evil because i want you watch a nature
documentary where they attack a baby
antelope because it's the slowest and
they can catch it it's the easiest to
eat is that evil empty i don't know
right that's just the nature of that
animal and it's got to eat it's got to
feed
is it evil that it starts with the
stomach and is eating it while it's
still alive
we could argue that's pretty evil right
but a lion doesn't have the knowledge of
like suffering and pain and all that
right so it's like you could say that
zombie wand is the same way she's a more
it's almost like she's just a straight
predator she can't make the choice to be
good as the zombie so i don't think you
can call her evil she's just doing what
she's programmed to do you know what i i
100 agree there it's just like it's more
just like almost like just impulse in
like we do know that like like you said
she has this capacity for love because
she does feel
love for vision and attachment to vision
despite being a zombie so it's just like
you know her decisions are mainly just
things that she can't really control
which is
kind of like wanda in in what and
multiverse of madness it's like kind of
being pushed to do things that like are
into a way that's not really your fault
or your doing so like yeah i wouldn't
call her evil just uh probably more
darker just by nature because of like
what's going on with her and like sure
with a her chaos magic and b the fact
that she's a zombie infected by this
dark virus from the quantum realm who
knows where this virus
originated from like what this virus is
all about but like yeah she's definitely
darker in nature well okay so i guess
the question should be brandon out of
all these versions which version do you
think is the most savage i guess
we should say evil but like they're
those just like yeah i'm just gonna just
wreck shop and i think we know the
answer to this one
it's gotta be the six one six wonder
right yeah because we have to assume 100
we have to assume that christine palmer
has checked out and you know uh mr
fantastic right reed richards he's
leading the baxter foundation uh
christine's a senior fellow right i'm
sure they're checking out the multiverse
all over the place they've come across a
ton of wandas and they haven't seen one
that that was problematic enough to
warrant them to have their guard up when
616 strangers like wanda's coming
they're like nah not a problem we've
checked out the wanders they're cool so
i would say like in the known multiverse
like the 616 mcu wanda has got to be
like the most powerful the darkest and
dare i say evil
she's somewhat evil somewhat evil that's
okay that's okay
yeah that is okay because like like we
said this is the dark hold very much
influencing her decisions but like you
know i feel like rwanda has to take
several times because
she really
she's gotta take something trying to get
her kids back at all costs and like you
can't
kind of yeah if she had the choice to be
good at the end i feel like there's some
part of her that was making the choice
to be bad for all that time um right so
she she chose to let the people go she
let those people go so there is good
inside of her and she does make the
right decision when she's in the right
head space and when she's not being
corrupted by the dark cold she can make
the right decision but she is the most
dangerous now are a lot of people in the
mcu are to blame for that they gotta
stop lying to wanda they gotta stop
telling her she's not right or that
she's making up her kids guys pay
attention stop doing that to her treat
her with some respect seriously because
she is the most dangerous and she's not
gone she's coming back baby and she's
getting she's pissed off i'm telling you
like the the privacy of the scarlet
witch is has not been complete because
they said in the movie that she's either
going to destroy the universe or rule
the universe like in in a good way i
guess and i think option two is what's
going to happen and personally i think
that wanda is going to become the next
iteration of mcu infinity the the cosmic
being because oh
baby
ever since wanda destroyed vision she
has been absorbing infinity energy so i
think that she's just absorbing all this
energy for the purposes of being this
next infinity envision is going to be
eternity but that is my wild theory that
uh we'll see what happens after secret
wars but that's what i think is gonna
happen i love him but yes definitely
wanda 616 the most savage of all time um
freaking she freaking darth mauled
captain carter so that's pretty evil and
uh
i don't i never thought that would
happen but she's she's definitely a half
half off half off oh that's for sure but
anyways hey be sure to check out our new
rockstarsmerch.com website for our
newest latest obsession shirt shattered
madness inspired by the very doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
that we are talking about today once
it's sold out we will close the star
portal and it's gone for good you're not
gonna be able to open it up all right
you gotta call america chavez and maybe
you can find another shirt in another
universe so let this universe know that
you are the good variant by rocking our
merch 24 7 even when you sleep just
kidding you can take it off when you're
you know for other stuff that you have
to do no wear it while you sleep what if
someone comes for you in the night they
need to know that you're cool it's
perfect for never nudes never nudes love
new rockstarsmirch.com
and it's also a great way to support the
channel because like it helps us out a
lot so check out all of our merch
options over at new rockstarsmerch.com
because we have a lot of cool stuff and
before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people that help bring us big question
to you people like green chef do you
like cooking your own meals but panic
when it's time to actually figure out
what to make green chef makes cooking
easy so you can spend less time
stressing and more time enjoying
delicious home-cooked meals they provide
everything you need including fresh
produce premium proteins and organic
ingredients you can trust green chef is
the number one meal kit for eating well
green chef offers 24 always changing
recipes to choose from every week so you
never get bored and green chefs expert
chefs curate every recipe so you can
enjoy restaurant quality dishes at home
without compromising on taste and they
also help you cut down on food waste by
giving you the exact amount of food that
you need so stop throwing away food you
buy at the grocery store that you never
use like what that's ridiculous green
chef is the number one meal kit for
eating well with dinners that work for
you not the other way around and we've
used green chef here at new rockstars
and love the convenience and flexibility
that you can get from having meals
delivered directly to your door it makes
deciding dinner quick easy and fun so
try it for yourself go to chef dot com
slash big question 130 and use code big
question 130 to get 130 off plus free
shipping that's greenchef.com
bigquestion130
and use code big question 130 at
checkout green chef the number one meal
kit for eating well have you guys tried
dad grass yet oh man dad grass tell me
about dab grass oh i'll tell you about
dad grass dad grass 100 organic hemp
joints just got groovier to celebrate
the 50th anniversary of george
harrison's all things must pass album
dad grass has partnered with the
harrison estate to create a special
blend of cbd and cbg along with a
collection of token accessories called
all things musk grass did you catch that
pun huh did you catch it dad grass is
legal organic smokable hemp that relaxes
your body and mellows your mind they're
100 organic pre-rolled joints are very
low in thc and very high in cbd so you
can enjoy the effects of cbd while
keeping a clear head chill out without
getting stoned it's like having a glass
of wine not the whole bottle and all dad
grass products are federally legal for
ages 21 and over and it ships right to
your door anywhere in the united states
whether you're looking for a new buzz or
a chill way to enjoy an old favorite dag
grass will leave you in a euphoric mood
i've tried dagress
it's great i really enjoy it it's it's
super comfortable you don't feel super
high it's a great way to relax after
work or you're sitting down to watch
some tv or maybe check out multiverse of
madness what's that a woman cut me in
half with a shield oh my gosh i'm
stressed out but not on bad grass
feeling comfortable yeah i really like
dead grass it's it's awesome it feels
great it tastes great it's a fun
experience right now dad grass is
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
big question go to dadgrass.com
bigquestion for 20 off your first order
again that's dadgrass.com
big question all right dad grass um i
think moana wanted to get some mom grass
you know what i'm saying that maybe she
would chill the [ __ ] you have mom
driving too i don't know the difference
but yeah i don't know if she's high on
dad grass who knows what she could do
now it is time for our bite-sized
questions brandon this is where you it's
time for brandon to shop
now brendan we need that sweet sweet
information from that beautiful brain of
yours are you ready yes i'm ready
brandon how does kryptonite an element
from krypton have all sorts of different
effects on superman and this is from
piano bandana thank you so much piano uh
well kryptonite as we all know is the
radioactive green rock that comes from
superman's home planet of krypton and
it's the achilles heel for the man of
steel
the green kryptonite that is the most
common and prevalent form that we see it
comes from krypton's uh rocky crust it's
like just below the surface uh and it
was scattered across the cosmos when the
planet was destroyed but there's more
than just one color of kryptonite out
there empty there's also
gold kryptonite which comes from
krypton's core
uh there's less of gold kryptonite out
there because it was just the core and
not the crust so smaller you know
science uh and so it's very rare to find
gold kryptonite gold kryptonite can
permanently remove a kryptonian's powers
though in like post-crisis stories
they've made gold kryptonite only
temporarily remove the powers because
that's more fun right it's comic books
there's also they're always quick
that's comic books for you
also
guys if you have to write a comic for
like almost a hundred years things are
going to change every now and then okay
used to it there's also red kryptonite
out there uh which is just green
kryptonite that passed through this like
unknown crimson cosmic cloud on its way
to earth which changed it red
and red kryptonite has caused a variety
of strange effects in superman including
him becoming evil
losing his inhibitions where my
smallville fans at changing his
personality yes changing him into a
dragon red kryptonite can change
superman to a dragon uh it's caused uh
excessive hair loss in superman it's
caused rapid aging uh and it even caused
superman to shrink he shrunk did you
know that elaine superman can shrink
shrinkage
you mean shrink it yes
significant shrinkage
would you call her lola elaine
he called lois elaine oh elaine not lois
did you know that lois superman could
drink it shrinks it shrinks you put some
kryptonite next to the superman he could
shrink i was in the pool
listen if superman took a blue chew he
needs to take the red kryptonite to calm
himself down hey
yeah well like red kryptonite it has a
ton of effects it's different depending
on which story it is uh it's done a lot
of you i like how you brought up there's
actually most people yeah most people
didn't it made him it made him horny as
hell on small
he was a big guy he business
his parents yeah yeah
yeah he got near that red kryptonite
he's like get over here lois your man
ready to get down okay
i don't want to be a virgin no more
let's go lois
let's go
i'm not flying yet but i'm gonna get
in that bed you know what i'm talking
about superman here we go uh
there's actually there's like a whole
rainbow of colors of kryptonite that
have been introduced over the years both
in canon and out of canon uh here's a
long list of them right now
so many of uh elevator music magno
kryptonite
yeah
oh periwinkle kryptonite i but that's
cute oh my god
a red gold oh my gosh oh yeah these are
all on wikipedia tons of them tons of
them so yeah all these different
kryptonites uh different colors they all
come from krypton but why is it hurt
superman that's the question like why is
it hurting why is it having any of these
effects well the main thing is it's
radioactive like i said and similar to
how a human would be hurt by being
exposed to radioactive material a
kryptonian is harmed by kryptonite but
they're able to recover much faster from
the sun once the rock is like removed
from their general vicinity right uh the
way they describe it in the comic books
the radiation from kryptonite it blocks
the sun's power from getting to superman
or any other kryptonian so that's
generally how the kryptonite works to
harm superman its radioactivity is
blocking the helpful uv rays from
getting to our boy supes uh so yeah it's
just radioactive that's why it's
dangerous because you might be thinking
like well it's from his planet why does
it hurt him hey there's tons of
radioactive stuff on our planet that
hurts us you got to be careful don't go
digging around in your backyard you
never know what you might find this is
so true because like we could leave
earth and go to another planet and like
we could be their superman because like
of the various circumstances that they
got like
it's just so weird it's just like the
circumstances of our planet are just
really good for superman coincidentally
um but yeah that makes a lot of sense
because like radiation would harm anyone
if their planet has like had them
evolved to have that particular aversion
to that particular type of radiation so
they have shown in the comics that
kryptonite harms humans from earth over
a long period of time if you're exposed
to kryptonite for a long time you can
have harmful effects from it it just
works much faster on a kryptonian oh
thanks brandon that was a lot that's
really uh helpful i i had no idea that i
was even a thing so i learned something
new today too but i got another question
for you brandon who was the first marvel
comics character to have their own a
movie and this is from ranking burger
boy um thank you ranking burger [ __ ] i
hope you're number one in the ranking of
all burger boys
oh i hope so too i hope so too well to
answer your question it sort of depends
on what you consider to be a movie okay
so way back in 1944 there was a film
serial created by republic pictures
featuring a marvel comic book character
now a serial would like play before a
movie it would just be like a short
snippet
and then they would play the regular
movie and like they would change that
serial week to week so you'd have to
come back to the movie theater next week
to see the story continue right
and it would be fitting that the first
avenger was the first movie character
that's right this cereal featured our
boy captain america you can check it out
on youtube it's kind of metal like
there's a lot of people getting shot in
this
it's kind of crazy uh but yeah there
it's black and white because like that's
like we're literally 1944
world war ii propaganda yeah yeah they
were using it like that and like the
comic book had like just come out uh and
he's wearing kind of the outfit you
can't i mean it's black and white so we
don't know if it's like blue and red and
white but it's got the star he's got the
little cowl on it's it's our boy captain
america it's hilarious
[Music]
holy
captain america
but maybe you don't consider like a
serial to be a movie movie okay well
then let's jump ahead to 1977 where a tv
movie was made featuring spider-man
that's right the most popular character
was turned into like a tv movie but hey
you're sitting there you don't like this
answer still because you don't consider
a tv movie as a movie movie but if
that's your rules then you're also gonna
have to skip in 1978 they made a doctor
strange movie where he was like a
psychiatrist not a surgeon it was very
strange very strange and then in 1979
there's like a captain america tv movie
and they made a couple more of those so
yeah these are tv movies so maybe you
don't consider these that's fine that's
fine so that all leads us to the first
feature-length film that was released on
the big screen featuring a marvel comic
book character as the main character and
it is none other than everyone's
favorite character howard the duck
that's right released in 1986 the entire
mcu
rests on the shoulders of this alcoholic
water bird thank you howard the duck for
being the first
marvel comic books character to lead a
full-length feature film we tip our hats
to you howard the duck seriously hat
tipped if we do not see
original recipe howard the duck at any
point during the mcu like in secret wars
like honestly like straight up i've been
joking we have to see even though it's
nightmare fuel straight up like i don't
really particularly like it i like the
way he looks but like my god like he
this is history like he is the first
live action
marvel character so like put him in
there
respect your elders kevin feige you need
to you need to you need to break into a
closed down plane at hollywood and steal
the original howard the duck costume and
put it into a marvel movie you gotta yes
like listen if secret wars doesn't end
with original recipe how are the ducks
snapping the gauntlet
i don't want it like i really don't
but um but no thank you brenda this is
very enlightening uh but this leads us
to our box of scraps it's the box of
scraps built it in a cave with a buck
scraps now oh it's a bunch of scrap
perhaps
a whole ass box anyway um brandon what
multiversal version of yourself would
you like to trade places with oh buddy i
mean if there's an infinite enough
amount of universes out there and then
infinite versions of me uh i would like
to trade places with the version of
myself that is a cool skateboarder
that's right i've always wanted to be a
cool skateboarder doing cool
skateboarding tricks but i'm too scared
i'm a little baby boy i don't want to go
out there i could break my arm i could
break my head i could break my leg i'm
too scared i used to wear air walks in
middle school trying to pretend to be a
skater i wasn't a skater but it's time
for me to live the whole phase
yeah yeah i'm gonna trade places with my
my cool punk rock skateboarding itself
i'm gonna make that guy live here and
i'm gonna switch places with him that's
how i'm gonna do it yo i wanna see
brandon barracks pro skater 3. let's get
that going all right yeah brandon
barracks underground like he's getting
all over the mall
yeah up on the roof i'm doing i'm doing
like doing vhs tapes i'm doing i don't
even know i'm doing ollies
my god i yo i can totally see you as a
border i want to go like if i get a
universe hop i would go to your x games
bro i would be like in the first row
just cheering you on because i i know
you you you come home with me or however
that's games works i don't know what
they were the big x you get the big x
trophy i don't know um but no i really
love that one that's really fun for me i
mean everyone knows what's coming i know
i feel like i've answered a similar
version to this in the past or so i
don't know but the multiversal version
of myself that i would want to trade
places with is uh m t steinfeld i
guarantee you've never seen anything
quite so objectionable the one who's uh
wow we knew it we knew it
the one who was uh very fortunate to win
the heart of one haley steinfeld the the
greatest woman on this planet currently
um just kidding i mean like i'm
obviously not kidding but like i'm just
joking around i'm a simp a big old simp
what you can't see on the other side of
mt's computer is this big
this big wall this like wall with all
these
these clippings and these articles about
science and multiverses and and yarn and
stuff he's trying to figure it out as we
speak he's trying to crack open
basically and next to that is my uh you
know my hey arnold helga pataki shrine
of haley seinfeld uh
just kidding oh my god i'm a loser
anyway that's my answer
um because i just love her so much and
uh i cannot wait for season two of the
kate bishop program but that is it for
this episode a big question i want to
thank of course brandon as always for
joining me on this episode follow him at
grin and barrack on twitter he's amazing
man but follow me at masterchairman on
twitter not as cool but it's pretty it's
pretty all right at um at mastertainment
and also follow at new rockstars here on
youtube and all of our social media
platforms make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and hey if you want to continue
this conversation and all other types of
nerd conversations make sure to hit up
our discord using the link below in the
description box so you can join the
conversation and uh yeah we love you
guys so much like thank you guys so much
for spending time with us all the time
we really appreciate it and we will see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you